Let's start off by looking at some of the landscape sculpting tools.
So I'll just open my editor and jump in there now.
And with my editor open, I'm just in a default blank map here.
And I'm going to go to the selection mode and go to my landscape.
And you can change this to whatever size and scale you'd like.
I just want to work with something a little bit smaller here today just to give you an
idea of what's going on.
I'll leave my components the same there and I'll just hit create.
And then when we create, we also want to enable edit layers at the top left here.
And we'll show you what they do in a second as this gets loaded.
And now with the landscape loaded, you can see that we've got this landscape here that
we're preparing the shaders for as well.
But at least we can start editing the shaders.
So the landscape, sorry.
So you'll see by default, I have this sculpt tool here.
And what I can do is I can change the size of this by pressing the square bracket keys
next to my key enter key on the keyboard.
So by doing open bracket, it goes smaller.
Close bracket, it goes larger.
And you can see this brush size is being changed here.
So we can kind of just left click around to edit that.
And so you can kind of see that we have all these different tools here.
And if we go to flatten, we can kind of flatten out the landscape as well.
But lots of different tools and you can change the strength of the tool depending on the
result.
So brush size, brush fall off and the tool strength are going to be your friends here.
And you can play around with some of these settings, especially on this top row here,
just to kind of get the results that you're looking for on your landscape.
You can also see that when we enabled edit layers, we have a few functionality available
to us on our landscape.
So once the edit layers has been added, we can then rename them to something more useful
like a base mountains, roads, for example.
And then to use the edit layers, we first need to select a layer by clicking on it.
And then we just edit the landscape as we usually would.
So when we're done with that, we can just adjust the effect of the edit layer by adjusting
the alpha input.
So let's jump into the editor here and show you what's going on there.
So you can see as we previously had, we had our landscape here.
And you'll see that we have edit layers here.
So we can right click on this edit layers, we can rename this to say, base, for example.
And then we've, you know, edited this layer as we've been using that tool.
And then we can create a new one.
And let's say we just scope some more on top of this layer.
And you can see that then we can change the alpha of this layer to say how much of this
layer we actually want to add on top of that, which it can be really useful for kind of
painting in as we used in the previous example, the base and then the mountains and then the
roads.
So, you know, if I wanted to rename this mountain, for example, and just we can kind of make
it so that it's preserving the information from the base and layering up our information.
So edit layers might be useful for you, especially if you're doing a lot of detailed landscape
work.
And again, you can add as many layers as it takes to kind of get the results that you
want while preserving the data from the layer below.